Hãy dịch cuộc tuyến cho biết Việt bỏ thế khoảng và chuyển sang cửi chế hộ kinh dành từ kê khai từ sắc định dành thu.
Để thực hiện nghĩ vụ tuyến là lỗi dung được chín khai theo tình thần nghệ quế sống hi tám của một chính trị và chỉ đạo của chính vụ.
Điểm thành đổi lớn nhất hiện nay không năm tối sất mà ở tương thức quản lý.
Trước đây, hộ kinh dành có dành thu từ một chắc chờ đồng chiếm một năm chờ xuống, được miếng tuyến,
có hiện nay gửm dành thu, Việt tuyến được đăng lên một tỷ đồng chiếm một năm.
Bởi bởi nhỏ hộ kinh dành luật trởi theo tìm lệ trên sách thu, bất trởi sất cơ bản không thể đổi.
Bởi nhỏ trởi sách tự sắc định dành thu theo tháng hoặc quý đẹp kê khai.
Chào quán trình chín khai, cơ quan thuế phối hợp bởi các nhà cú cấp dải pháp công nghệ để hỗ trợ tuy đa cho hộ kinh dành.
Như phần bèm quản lý bán hàng, khoảng đoình tự, chữ ký số và các gọi dịch cuộc phu hợp bởi tự quy mốt kinh dành đã được cú cấp.
Trong đào có nhiều gọi Việt vĩ trong gia đòn đầu.
Theo lấy đạo cuộc tuy ấy, qua tổng kết bất đầu khoảng chiếm tảm phần trăm hộ kinh dành thu kinh dành kê khai đã thực hiện lũng và kịt thời.
Các quan thuế cũng thường suyên theo dõi hỗ trợ chịch kép, nhằm tháo gửa các gương mắt phát sinh trong quá trình chình dụi.
Cục tuy đẹp giá về át dụng phương tức khoảng lý mới bất đầu mắt lại nhiều dí hiệu tích cửc.
Vó phật nâng cao tính bích bà chong hoàn đầu kinh dành.
Vìa kênh khai dân thủ theo thực tế cũng suy hành trế tình chẳng, vân thu thay đổi.
Lý kông được nhiều trình kịt thời nhí trước đây, từ đó giảm quyết thích tuy tụi tối,
thời gian tối ngành tuy ấy sẽ tiếp tục ra soát khoảng tiện các quy định tăng nghi định thông tư và hướng dẫn kẻ cắt thủ tục hành trính.
Dạm tạo thuật lời hơn cho hộ kinh dóan.
Cơ quan tuy ấy sẽ tiếp tục phối hợp với các nâng vĩ của cấp dải pháp công nghệ.
Nè mọi giống các cốc cú hỗ trợ, giúp hộ kinh dây dạm thực hiện nghệ vụ thui và dành thay rất là ec cốc tức khoảng tiệ mới.